it just looks like I have an extended
weird knee like this oh is that weird
guy said yeah that's mr. pedals in the
background of a video once and ever like
every single comment was just like who's
that man in the back we're doing it
we're doing it yeah I'm here with Ingrid
Nilsen yes it's amazing Nelson Nelson I
want to say like Nielson cuz like
Brigitte Nielsen I don't know if I
should know II at the beginning get it
right people found it out found it out
uh miss glamour rot see if you didn't
know you should know and she's here to
record an episode of not too deep my
podcast so make sure you go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud and listen to that
full podcast but while she was here I
thought we'd play a game because that's
just what we do game games and Ingrid I
think you have a really good sense of
smell because you seem to like really
good food yes and I feel like just not
good food yeah I feel like that's part
of it and so I saw rhett and Link and
mamrie Hart play the game recently
called you deserve a stink in which they
were blindfolded and had to guess the
smells of what they were smelling so I
thought we'd play that today yeah you
all I keep thinking it's on a pile of
poop it's just gonna end up in front of
my friend that's what I keep thinking
there won't be any [ __ ] in this video
other than the feeling of loss for the
loser of this game okay Jack Ferry has
gone out and purchased things for us to
smell are they all edible no are any of
them why they're definitely not all
edible is anything alive I don't want to
tell you too much so we're both gonna
blindfold ourselves and smell the item
at the same time and try to rapid fire
gas and whoever guesses the correct item
first gets a point the first person that
five points is the winner all right okay
so man my heart's actually rate let's
put these blindfolds on um do you have
any allergies I should ask this haha
this is oh my god this is
this is the time where we both get
double pranked I feel like is it in
front of us I'm trying to use my other
senses to figure it out yeah I need to
look good
I'm sorry okay I just don't of you grace
it's not you oh whoa oh my god wait wait
wait wait you want to go it's lingering
I guess tuna tuna yeah they're tuna if
not it's cat food yeah do we both have a
point both of a point yeah okay hands
this is also trust me by this point I
honest no oh what the ha ha no it's not
good wait I know what this is be holy
crap can I start guessing yeah yeah
chocolate cake you know I wish that me
just wishing for it Oh can I smell it
one more time yeah that's what I'm like
sputtering smells like something so
familiar why does moving something
horrible coconut but bad coconut like
rancid coconut oil yeah like you said it
coconut oil it's coconut oil yeah Oh
coconut oil smell stanky wait for the
next one okay so it's two to one you
want what is it that's not a metal whoa
what the my heart oh my god oh my god
what is it it kind of does smell like
these beans black beans it doesn't smell
dog food dog food well stop people hate
that yeah tomato soup chicken noodle
soup the chicken noodle soup no dad it's
tuna soup SpaghettiOs huh you got it Oh
Oh oh my god yeah we're gonna come back
okay so it's three two one okay whoo
that's like what the heck wait it's like
sweet is it is it Glade plugin I'm out
is it hand soap is it it's like is it is
it poo pourri no god damn it
yeah it doesn't smell like something
that you eat and this is where we find
out that they're holding human [ __ ] I
know I'm asking it like a lavender so is
it a laundry item
no is it dryer sheets no but I know it
you said no to the light side and then I
followed up thanks my deodorant
yes why were we all these other things
why did we do safety outer it because
three to two yeah okay
something smells floral isn't open yet
oh oh oh shoot yeah that's cat food it's
all mine laughing oh that's cat food
that's cat or dog food it's or yeah yeah
dummy does not smell good no sorry dogs
yeah okay so it's for two - yeah for two
- all right it's go time
well I mean have you taste you've tasted
baby food I have yeah that is fed to
human yeah what are we doing ah in an
effort to make them grow
okay this is a good one yeah well I
don't know what you define as good
anymore cuz this jack is just making
himself dinner right now
really uh-huh I'll bet adopted oh yeah
what angry wait I think I know that's
can we guess yes where's Emma
vodka scale thanks guys
yeah I know that I didn't get that but I
know your whisky yeah I'd like to say
the one item I guess with conviction
okay oh it's four to three
that's right oh my gosh there are no
winners here is what we've determined up
okay grace Oh
I mean it's minty mouthwash yeah ah yeah
it's all tied up right literally all
tied up yeah what what shake it up is it
Taylor Swift good what was that
it smells like if you have a guess go
for it I am wet the it smells like
cucumber yeah I was gonna say celery oh
it's like a cucumber celery juice yes
winner
can we unkind phones unless you want to
do like a sudden death rhymes then you
have one more
okay I feel like that no cuz we're
getting both start rapid-fire guessing
as soon as we smell there it is
garlic what onion red onion yeah oh
hello world oh wow right this is like
being born again I won but I don't know
that I actually won because that was a
symphony of smells oh yeah it really was
what a variety thank you for that
variety I just sorted to think what else
could Jack buy at the grocery store are
there any sense in there that we didn't
yeah a woman vitamin knows oh that was
been so easy why I lost if you guys
don't want to miss out make sure you go
check out the full podcast Anna anger
and I did not too deep over on iTunes
and SoundCloud Ingrid where can people
find you all across the lovely internet
on YouTube they can find me on Twitter
on Instagram and snapchat and everything
is just my name that's so easy talk
about brand building except on snapchat
there's a dot between the firsts and
left oh yeah everyone took all the good
snapchat name now we hate them I eat the
banana that's your price yeah by
pregnant for Lizzy I'll see you guys
next time I don't know because that's
move nugget II know sombrero I got him
this little mini sombrero on my way back
from Mexico oh my god
I saw these mini sombreros and I was
just like I have to put it on nugget